Shaq size has always been part of his
dominance but he's recently revealed
that his weight fluctuated over 130 lb
during his playing career crazy right
let's break it down when sha came in the
league he was obviously huge 300 lb is
not out of this world for a center
especially in the '90s early 2000s but
during the Lakers Dynasty years Shaq's
weight would climb to massive levels
from 315 in his first championship to
345 in the repeat to 385 in the three
peat and maxing out at a BRC 415 lbs
before his trade to Miami but when Shaq
got to the heat Pat Riley wasn't going
for that he put Shaq on the South Beach
plan AKA Army drills which got Shaq back
down to 325 lbs before that Championship
as Shaq got older and went to other
teams his physique would change but as
of now he's still Shaq diesel being
around 375 even using his gym time to
show fans how he's working on the games
but it's crazy that no matter what
weight Shaq played at his dominance